[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now this
weekend we're going to rock
and run for a great cause here to tell
us more about the first ever rock and
run 5k race
is musician ryan patrick who's the
founder of life by music
ryan tell us more about the organization
jc how's it going man
yeah non-prof uh life music is a
nonprofit we started
and are so focused
we're freezing up we're freezing up and
get instruments to kids who need them
we froze out there for a second but the
key thing is you guys get instruments to
the kids that need them which is which
is a huge thing
here in las vegas and then saturday is
the first ever rock and run
5k race it's happening at sunset park
what can we expect at the race
so uh we're gonna be running my band
mates and i are gonna be running in the
race
and uh we've got some fun stuff going on
uh
at sunset park it starts at 7 30 a.m and
then that night we're celebrating
on the green at the las vegas golf
center we're gonna be playing a rock
show
so we're gonna get fit in the morning
and then we're gonna rock and roll in
the evening yeah let's break down the
run here for a second so k
is is it a run walk is it a fun walk and
then is it open to everyone is there
capacity
can we do it virtually tell us more
about the race yeah absolutely
so you can sign up on lifebuymusic.org
we're going to do a 1k
walk and also a 5k run and there's going
to be
chip race timing it's going to be a
full-on 5k so if there's runners out
there who want to
want to practice this weekend at sunset
park with us and raise some funds for a
good cause
yeah i'm everybody's invited so where
did the concept where the whole idea of
this race where'd you guys
get the concept from well this is some
this has been a dream i've wanted to be
able to do something for
the community in the morning and then
celebrate at night so
it just came together we had the crazy
idea of putting it together and and
all the permits and regulations have
come in and we're ready to go
so it's a very exciting time we've
really wanted to do something like this
for a while now and we're finally making
it happen
i love this because saturday morning
we'll be racing and then you'll be tired
after the race you can recover
and then talk about the concert that's
happening on saturday because you got a
nice little lineup
including yourself performing on
saturday night yeah there's a handful of
artists who uh donated their time to the
to the show we have uh damaris cure the
curse
elvis monroe and earl turner they're all
gonna come and perform
and we're just gonna have a good time
the doors are at 5 p.m it's outside
on the driving range we're pulling in a
mobile stage
and it's going to be something special
it's going to be a great weekend so how
do people register for the race
yes uh you go to lifebymusic.org and you
can sign up there you can buy
your a registration to the race you can
buy raffle tickets we've got a really
cool raffle going on a lot of local
businesses have donated some really
wonderful things
and then there's also concert tickets
available
thank you thank you so much buddy don't
forget to stretch before you race on
saturday we appreciate it
in las vegas now we'll be right back